what's up guys i'm greg and i'm aaron
we're gonna watch the penultimate
episode of umbrella academy season two
it is called 743. thank you everyone
who's been watching so far
hit that subscribe button click that
notification bell so you get notified
when our reaction to the last umbrella
kevin rini episode is up it's at academy
as a friendly reminder youtube only
allows about 10 minutes of footage if
we're lucky of the show to be included
so this is qualifiers reaction
highlights full length reaction watch
longs are over at our patreon page
we really appreciate if you guys can go
show your support over at patreon
over there we do tv show reactions for
many shows full length reaction watch
alongs reaction highlights included
all at the same tier for look at all
these photos my god
so many photos so many shows can greg
shut up about this at the beginning of
umbrella academy i don't think so
we also got a weekly q a podcast let's
do this
oh damn straight out allison
hit it no time for games
damn
[Laughter]
hey you can do it diego just will power
[Music]
couldn't ben go in there
ben's ass in there come on oh
that's a sore neck come on dude go wake
up
who who is that oh is that vania
come on man
you're not of this plane come on i was
like yeah man here it goes get in there
possess money there whoa that's
interesting spot for an umbrella
great opener
[Laughter]
yes
what you're such a bad liar he's gonna
kill you okay
oh my god is he gonna kill us himself
[Laughter]
wow this is so fascinating
i'm a child
yeah the best use of farting in a
television show
to enhance the stakes
[Laughter]
you loyal herb
can herb not tell that that's the same
fish
now he's vicious
oh yeah there we go
oh you smart fish does the
handler not recognize that herb is
probably checking
exactly
and just like that that grip she's
you just ensured lila's betrayal she
looks like the
the queen from the huntsman the snow
white and the huntsman
the charlotte's dinner plate the ice
cream oh totally i see it i forgot i
don't know what the name of i don't like
that movie
[Laughter]
743 title of the episode
wow ben you could have done this in
season one oh i totally got it
is that vania
oh is he gonna do it
holy [ __ ]
oh harlan i hope you murdered your dad
murder your daddy boy
where you gonna take the boy
whoa yeah maybe you don't deserve him
anymore
shoot that man shoot that man
[Music]
damn songs
are you really gonna kill him of course
not i love
show you something him
i'm not as small as you think
what i think it's her file yeah i was
going to say are you smart fishy
[Laughter]
he likes this [ __ ]
but he had to change a heart before
[Music]
are you smart [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] oh
my own balls oh [ __ ]
a night crawler off
meat that's a game that's a cool scene
guys pull your [ __ ] together come on
y'all we gotta save the world
you did all those brawls man you could
drink i hid in the nuts before i hit one
of them
oh whoa he's really entered her mind
he's really in there
it's not just body possession that's
cool i really like that
ben is so much more included this season
yeah it's a progressive show
in every sense of the word
bloody strings oh whoa
that's a trip there's layers
[Music]
oh
it's a shitty
you're breaking my heart ben you are
oh you're a good guy
oh no is he dying no no no no no no
no no what no
no no no
oh wow
oh man wait a minute but ben was at the
beginning of the
when when they were fighting russia at
the first episode of the season but they
just changed it
because five was actually there oh yeah
and then they stopped the whole nukes
from go oh yeah
that's [ __ ] up why would you play good
for you you don't get points with it
yeah
wow you're gonna hurt the data
accidentally shoot the kid stop it he's
gonna stop it
yeah boy
[ __ ] damn son
wow carl was the real villain of this
wow
time to join the good side
what oh
[ __ ] oh
that's why we didn't see him i thought
it was gonna be freaking hazel
wow you're blowing my [ __ ] mind here
you're a lion you're a lion woman i
don't know why turn off christopher
walken
not a good walk not a great [ __ ] i'm
walking away from that accident
don't fall for this place
[Music]
oh no oh oh
[ __ ] fish is there
oh wow
oh what just happened
one just moved
that's probably the smartest plan you
could do
that's cool whoa
freaks out again
[Laughter]
[Music]
daddy hogwarts
umbrella camera oh bro
uh i don't know what the [ __ ] you're
saying
make sure he doesn't take the briefcase
make sure he doesn't take the briefcase
right
that's so smart because he totally did
throw it in
no
let's watch him get shot
i want him to do it
it's not him who does it though dumbass
it's not your dad [ __ ]
told you um
he's still involved in some way though
yeah obviously
oh hey carter is going to murder them
our little kennedy problem was solved
it was not to be touched that was the
deal so what did he want to keep giving
us technology of yours
because if you don't we'll kill you
don't tell the world
who you really are who is he really is
he an alien i'm like they've said just
yet
he really is oh yeah he's going to kill
them all right
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
what is he doing dude you were right he
is an alien
what the [ __ ]
oh
jesus
dude you call that on like the first or
second episode
did you watch this show already
[Laughter]
like hinted at in season one that he
could have been from another planet
saw that [ __ ] coming um geez
louise just left it in there yeah i
can't believe hari is it alien
that's nice i hope we see his face
oh what so what was on the screen i
missed that
i don't think they showed us oh the boy
they're talking about the boy
okay okay what the hell
what what are you doing what you doing
in there
oh man that was about short right
that was a quick one that was a quick
phone really short
damn wow one last one
there are a lot of surprises in that
episode there's a short episode it's
only 40 minutes yeah it went by like
super quick a lot of great episodes i
was getting a little misty when ben
passed away yeah i did the game in the
fields i was like oh
like it was so sweet and i was like
we've never seen ben and bonnie have a
moment together and it was just the
sweetest event i could never see my eyes
i was watching thinking in the very last
episode at the ending of it that's
and it picks up right away here we were
both saying like why doesn't ben just go
in because i was on the impression
because just walk up to her and at least
just physically touch her to be like
cut the [ __ ] yeah i didn't think he was
gonna do this whole
inception into her mind and talk to her
directly
go into the room of her mind inside the
violin that's in her room mind
yeah just a whole thing but yeah it was
it was interesting
i didn't know ghosts could do that it
was very endearing dialogue
i love that line that he says of dad
treated you like a bomb before you even
went off
yeah and you said you're not a monster
you're my sister you're my sister which
is so beautiful and he has such a
compassionate understanding
towards her which is on display even
with like the
colossus cult of how he's he's a ghost
so he doesn't get to interact so all he
gets to do is really observe
right and through being observant he
probably has the best form of
communication of having a proper heart
to heart with people
exactly and having that dialogue
exchange i thought was necessary and
important especially for vanya's
character to show some real growth here
because yeah she did do some horrible
things she
caused the end of the world she did
murder pogo and
she did almost go allison i thought like
for to do one
solid scene like that for me at least as
i'm from this perspective i'm watching
it going i feel like that's good enough
for vanya's arc
you know and like she still has more to
do to probably
do some redemption but she doesn't have
to do that much redemption to a certain
extent and none of this
is her fault right you know like even
the end like you have to take
responsibility for the actions you did
at the same time though she was raised a
very specific way that caused her to to
turn out like this and no one's been
able to have this conversation
even with her knowing the truth of some
stuff no one's been able to have this
direct conversation with her because
this is the first time they're getting
that chance to
her actually remembering who she is and
stuff did you also get the sense like
when they have that scene between ben
and vania that this was the same vania
from season one
no really because i feel like she still
had all the guilt of like everything she
was doing and i feel like i don't know i
feel like
vonnie from season oh oh oh like without
more like common drum and like feeling
the guilt of like
oh wait no i get what you're saying i
thought she was like i feel like she was
like
by the time she was talking with them
she felt like a hybrid of the two yeah
that's that's why i was gonna
look once i started getting what you
were saying i was gonna say exactly that
i'm saying that i feel like she has
grown into this version because she got
to be the
version she was when she's with [ __ ]
and then she
gets to be that version of who she was
with [ __ ] of with her
siblings in the 60s and then having all
the memories she feels like uh
a character that has truly evolved into
something more
i really like ellen page's performance
uh in these last few episodes especially
and uh that scene with ben was great and
what a beautiful
send-off like visually that was gorgeous
visually that was just absolutely
beautiful
yeah it was just tragic he just hugged
me him fading away
as like they embrace i was like very
sci-fi fantasy
you got a whole bunch of other stuff
here that happens in the episode too for
a short episode they have a lot of big
reveals
yeah i think the pacing of it was just
so so smooth you didn't even feel it
was like oh it's over already yeah that
whole showdown between
five and five right i mean those two
actors were
whoever they got to play older five and
what's great is older five and younger
five they work so well together they're
so perfect
it's believable that this is the older
version or the younger version of
this younger older five yeah and i loved
i really really loved how they brought
back
the because i remember in uh season one
the firs the first episode of the show
yeah class throws in the fire
extinguisher the fire extinguisher
they brought that back and then it plays
into the plot here of knocking luther
down that was great that was brilliant
because it was already like cool to be
like oh look you're seeing the
perspective from here the portal
of five's perspective [ __ ] it is i
thought that was cool then having the
fire extinguisher moment like that whole
scene was a lot of fun
it was a clever callback i wonder if
they use that same footage from the
portal's perspective from season one or
they reshoot that
for right the old five that he's going
back now wouldn't he be
old now yeah or was he bullshitting i
think he was telling the truth was the
the thing about the uh the calculation
he was saying because like was it a
calculation on his
portal yeah it was the appearance so he
i thought the calculation was that way
he could go back and not have to look
like a little boy again
by no but does he make calculations when
he times travels with his own power
that's what i was confused about i don't
know they were saying a whole bunch of
science stuff
doesn't matter if i'm reading subtitles
i have no idea what's being said right
now
like this is this is beyond my computer
i don't know if jfk gets killed
and then vania is not doing it this
whole thing with harlan that they're
revealing though
is that supposed to allude to the fact
cause because handler says we're at war
so is that alluding to oh we still have
the possibility of having a doomsday
because of harland
possibly the source of the explosion
comes from a different source now the
initial incident of the explosion comes
from harlan as opposed to fania
yeah like for there being a threat i'm
not sure because
if we when you look at that scene with
the handler before she stabs the guy in
the control room you see like
images of harley and all in the
background so right clearly they've had
their eye on him for some reason for
some extent
but um i mean i liked all that stuff
with [ __ ] finally standing up to carl
carl being like the biggest [ __ ] ever
yeah
carl is the worst i don't blame you for
what happened with our kid
the husband of the freaking yeah get out
of here bro when uh
harlan deflected the bullet though and
they killed carl i was wondering why the
writers went with that particular choice
because i was like thinking
well it might be a completely different
emotional type of turmoil
if harlan directly just kills his dad so
i guess they're like wrote in it has to
be some type of deflecting thing
he may still feel that guilt of killing
his dad that's true
they still got to have the moment though
beforehand where [ __ ] gets to have
her growth have her arc and stand up to
the man who's been abusive to her that
actress is
dynamite she is solid i hope she comes
back for season three if they get a
season three if she survives if she
survives i mean they're definitely gonna
have a season three this is what
this has been like this is not a popular
show it's been top ten on netflix for
like
weeks now yeah it's gonna come back
carl out of the pitcher [ __ ] having her
arc and then whatever's going on in the
barn right there it looks like harlow's
having some weird freak out episodes
yeah
like how does he handle all this oh
cause he has his fit still
yeah exactly so we don't know how that's
all playing in whatever disabilities he
has so whatever like conditions he has
and then how that factors in with the
new discovery of powers not knowing what
to do
it's like yeah vanya is on the way other
side of town though united with her
siblings
it wasn't made clear vanya is aware of
her connection with harlan and what she
was doing if that was igniting something
in him you know so she has to find
somebody to get in touch but the
apocalypse should at least be postponed
for a little bit now wait a minute wait
a minute i just realized something as
we're talking about this
so this whole entire show when harlan
was in it he didn't really speak right
he said vania at the end in the episode
he would say he would make
some make like noises but i don't think
he would say like words or names
i don't know i don't know correct us
correct me i don't know i'm curious to
know if the
how they're going to further utilize the
connection between
vania and harland we got only one more
episode to go
one more baby i'm hyped i'm so excited
okay so then you got this thing with
five the lila
situation yeah the 743 documents
that was nuts i was like oh snap i was
going to confront her mom
they're like that makes sense why they
wouldn't show the person at the
beginning because it's fine the whole
time
it was a great reveal i was like
wonderful like they were clearly masking
him but then i eventually i
i was like yeah maybe they're just you
know yeah whoever did it wasn't
important so i thought that was a great
reveal i just
felt like wouldn't aj have some type of
he said 743 so wouldn't he have
some not some sort of backup planner
like wouldn't it show that
she was the one behind it yeah if he was
the higher up what was he hoping for
then
right yeah i think he was hoping to
expose the mom but when it showed the
flashback
she used aj's stamp as opposed to her
own style and he just had no
knowledge of that he wasn't aware of
that i wouldn't
but wouldn't her be aware that herb or
aj wasn't aware that herb
had the document i think he was showing
for her
just for her knowledge not to double
trade the handler
but my question is why would
handler order this in the first place
was her intention to like oh i need a
daughter let's just kill these
these two yeah that's right i haven't
made that clear yeah i wonder if there's
more to lyla than we
know but it doesn't make sense why why
she would do that in the first place aj
and herb
really did not think this one through
terrible team but if five can remember
he could probably talk to lyla and be
like that
handler is the one who ordered this you
know this is true
yeah so that could be he has no he's
killed so many people i'm sure you
wouldn't even remember
probably by this point yeah but now aj
is dead
or maybe he's not digested and she'll
poop him out maybe she'll poop him out
the revival of aj we did see in season
one
she uses the bathroom sometimes
[Laughter]
these are facts
and then of course uh not being able to
save jfk
but the reveal the official confirmation
that hargraves is in fact
not of this world not an alien i have
not seen these episodes before
this was speculation and i was [ __ ]
frightened
that's crazy man yes that is crazy so
i want to see his alien face dude what
the hell is that back of the thing on
the back of his head
because they had they still haven't
explained yet you know all the children
born around the world and now hargraves
collected seven of them is he behind it
yeah like did he create this thing to
happen did he create this anomaly to
happen
i mean he did release those little glowy
sparkly things in the air then vania
breathed that into harlan so maybe
someday i don't know that's what i mean
we still have no knowledge of how
they came to be all the [ __ ] we're
focused on and we're still having to
explain the origin
dude i'm so excited there's so much
there's so much to dig into this show
there's like so much knowledge let's see
what information is revealed in the next
episode guys
all right people well what'd you think
of this episode make sure to hit that
like button if you liked the episode or
if you liked our reaction
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell check us out on
patreon
uh appreciate you guys being here and
last but not least
can't go further with umbrella academy
shout outs if i'm not shouting out
jt who i know watches this show
808 shadow is what he has renamed
himself
if you guys might be in your shoes what
the hell does the 808
shadow mean well here's the thing at our
patreon
we have an exclusive tier kind of hidden
kind of like the secret menu in and out
where basically it's a sex
chat it's a sex chat roulette it's great
jt
didn't want his actual name to be used
there's a username for our chat room
so he changed it to the 808 shadow 808
being a symbolism for like because he's
got four testicles so
the two eight it's four balls and then
the zero
being you know big long bulbous penis
yeah
exactly so that's what the 808 shadow
means because
he just sneaks a photo in once in a
while yeah and then he he puts a shadow
over his face so
jt hope you're enjoying umbrella academy
love the new username
glad we could share with everyone good
luck finding that tear
jt i'm sorry no that's true your dad's a
cop i don't want him to come
knocking on my door oh my i mean keep it
sexy but yeah keep it legal
bye jc bye
[Music]
you